and in India more than 130 people were
killed when a pedestrian bridge
collapsed in the western state of
Gujarat large crowds were celebrating a
religious religious Festival over the
Macho River when cable supporting the
bridge snapped
survivors were
Switzerland Bridge
others clinging to the cables and
climbing up the remains of the bridge to
escape the water
the accident happened in morby a city in
the Western Indian state of Gujarat
prime minister Narendra modi's home
state
more than a hundred people were on the
structure when it collapsed
some were moving on the bridge and got
injured While others fell into the water
we started a rescue operation
immediately and took the injured people
to the hospital
authorities believe most of the victims
are children women and elderly people
emergency responders from neighboring
districts were deployed to the scene to
help with rescue efforts
the accident comes just days after the
19th century colonial era Bridge was
reopened to the public after renovations
our South Asia bureau chief America
joins me now from Delhi Amrita what's
the latest on the rescue operation
you had rescue operations have been
going through the night but of course
it's been very challenging to find
survivors at night and now the rescue
operation is in full swing with multiple
agencies involved the national Disaster
Response forces there various teams have
been sent from the armed forces from the
Army the Navy and the Air Force divers
have been brought in swimmers have been
brought in they've deployed amphibious
boats to look for survivors particularly
survivors or bodies which may have gone
Downstream and they're also using drones
for this search and rescue operation now
one Army official that I heard he was
talking about there being maybe several
people or rather more likely bodies
trapped under the debris of the
collapsed Bridge
uh now the bridge had apparently just
reopened after renovation Works uh are
there any doubts whether that bridge has
been properly checked for safety
many doubts uh um Gerhard in fact that
is the burning question how could a
bridge which had gone through months of
Renovations be opened and collapsed
within just days of reopening now there
are obviously a lot of theories to that
people are also asking themselves why
were so many people allowed on a bridge
about 500 people are meant to have been
on the bridge when it collapsed now a
special tribunal has been set up to
investigate these questions as well as a
technical committee now of course
they'll take some time to come up with
their conclusions but they are initial
reports that a cable snapped under
perhaps the share weight of the number
of people on the bridge and they're also
very disturbing reports coming out
reports which say that the company which
actually renovated the bridge did not
have a fitness certificate from the
local Municipal Corporation and then the
question arises why didn't authorities
allow people on the bridge there also
reports that the maintenance company
which was looking after the Bridge
opened the bridge ahead of schedule and
they use this holiday season to make a
bit of money they even issued tickets to
people to go onto the bridge now this is
always disturbing reports and they need
to be investigated
what's been the official reaction there
to this huge loss of life
there's been obviously um the Swift
reaction from prime minister Narendra
Modi 's his State Gujarat is his State
and he's actually there on a visit he's
made speeches about giving
his sympathies and condolences to the
next of kin he says he shares the pain
that the people of morbi are feeling
he's also announced compensation for the
next of Ken for those who've died as
well as the chief ministers also uh
offered compensation and there have been
of course reactions from politicians
from across the political Spectrum all
of them sharing the pain that the people
in morbi are feeling and also of course
asking questions how this could happen
so there's also a bit of a political
blame game which has started experts say
we have the policies we have the
framework is this a question of not
being implemented properly so we just
have to wait and see what the
investigation brings out
the W South Asia bureau chief Amrita
Chima they're reporting from Delhi thank
you very much Amrita